bonsoir le 7 8 reprend pour une nouvelle
semaine une heure pour faire le point
sur l'actualité du département dès 18h
en direct première invitée ce soir joël
regnault bonsoir soir le maire de
plaisir vous allez nous accompagner
durant la première partie de cette
édition du 12 novembre et nous allons
expliquer les raisons de votre départ
puisque vous allez démissionner de ce
poste de maire de la commune
ce sera le 15 novembre lors d'un conseil
municipal extraordinaire
la seconde partie du 7-8 ce sera avec
anthony rech bonsoir anthony salle
wilfrid et ce soir dans la page sports
la chronique sport du judo du rugby du
foot les des castors et des castors mais
tout d'abord nous partirons en mer avec
le vendée globe qui est parti ce week
end je vous donnerai les toutes
premières nouvelles de tanguy de lamotte
le skipper versaillais fait partie des
19 navigateurs solitaires qui ont quitté
samedi midi les les sables d'olonne pour
ce tour du monde à la voile sans escale
et sans assistance nous parlerons aussi
de castor arrivera lundi sionnel course
d'orientation à temps organisé par le
guillon cours orientation est au
programme du judo avec le bushi de club
de trappes qui organise son traditionnel
tournoi international
ce week-end où s'affronteront près de
1500 combattants et puis comme
d'habitude en fin de chronique tous les
résultats du week end ce sera dans une
vingtaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
anthony on découvre à présent les
principaux sujets les reportages que
vous allez découvrir au cours de cette
édition les titres en images nous irons
à trappes pour entendre le témoignage
d'un chirurgien de l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien une grève dans les
hôpitaux à l'appel de 28 syndicats
organisations professionnelles s'est
tenue aujourd'hui des médecins souvent
discret qui montent au créneau pour
dénoncer les propos de leur ministre de
tutelle
en ce lundi 12 novembre du mouvement
dans les transports avec de nouvelles
lignes de bus créer d'autres modifier
l'objectif mieux desservir la zone
d'activités à de trappes elancourt un
projet est de près de 300000 euros
financés par des collectivités publiques
et des entreprises
les scream club de trappes porte en lui
des graines de champions jéromine mba
jean gars et cédric n quennesson les
espoirs de l'écriture escrime français à
19 ans ils ont la même arme le fleuret
est pas la même approche de la
discipline vous le verrez
gabriel parle ware a été nommé cette
saison capitaine de l'as montigny en
balles elles marquent en moyenne par
match 7 buts c'est l'atout offensif du
club qui s'est imposé d'ailleurs ce week
end
on débute donc par cette grève depuis ce
lundi les médecins libéraux clament leur
colère notamment à l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien à trappes 90% des
chirurgiens libéraux et des
anesthésistes sont grévistes un secteur
professionnel entend rarement le motif
de leur colère à l'accord sur les
dépassements d'honoraires signé fin
octobre par trois syndicats de médecins
selon eux est la ministre de la santé
les accuse de tous les maux et ce n'est
pas admissible
on va écouter ce témoignage d'un
chirurgien moi je suis en secteur 2 je
suis chirurgien de la main
j'ai créé ici à trappes à l'hôpital
public parisien un des plus gros centres
et serez sman france j'exerce mon
activité à plus de 55% au tarif
opposable 55 % des gens qui viennent me
voir non pas un centime à débourser pour
leurs soins alors on est en train
d'expliquer aux médecins qui comme moi
ont secteur ne font plus de la moitié de
leur activité au tarif opposable qui
travaille pas bien mais c'est quoi ce
délire
la ministre accuse les médecins d'être
responsable d'un mal être social
alors que nous nous sommes les soignants
c'est nous qui soignons les français
c'est nous qui nous occupons de alors
s'il ya des problèmes de remboursement
des français c'est pas de notre faute
c'est pas nous qui font qu'ils sont les
tarifs opposables c'est pas nous qui
fixons les tarifs des assurances
complémentaires
oui il y à des compléments d'honoraires
oui quelques médecins quelques dizaines
de médecins français font des
compléments qui sont au-delà de ce qui
pourrait être commandable très bien le
conseil de l'ordre est là pour faire le
ménage à trappes malgré le taux de
grévistes la continuité des soins est
assurée et les patients nouvellement
arrivées transférés vers d'autres
établissements le mouvement a démarré
sur les réseaux sociaux il ya trois
semaines est sur le terrain depuis ce
lundi la grève est illimitée mercredi et
christian couturier ira à manifester à
paris devant le ministère de la santé
l'invité de cette première partie du set
suite joël regnault maire de plaisir
vous allez donc quitter votre poste le
15 novembre le rôle d'un conseil
municipal extraordinaire avant de nous
donner les raisons de ce départ un
chiffre le chiffre de cette édition 11
c'est le nombre d'années que vous avez
passé en tant que mère dans cette
commune presque douze années passées en
tant que maire est précisément de maire
puisque vous avez si j'ai depuis les
années 80 vous faites un dans
l'opposition on a trop voilà alors
expliqué c'est votre première entrée au
conseil municipal 1,83 donc dans
l'opposition
expliquez-nous les raisons de ce départ
mars 2014 normalement élections
municipales vous avez décidé de devancer
l'appel
oui j'ai souhaité anticiper le passage
du témoin je pense que c'est comme cela
que j'ai essayé pendant toutes ces
années et vous le rappeliez à quelques
mois de 12 années de responsabilité
eh bien j'ai souhaité tout simplement
comme dans une entreprise anticipées ce
passage de relais
c'est important parce que on ne peut
plus prendre de risques avec les
collectivités on est bien placé
malheureusement pour le savoir c'est ce
qui a expliqué notre arrivée en 2001 et
je souhaite profondément permettent aux
plaisirs oiseaux plaisir war de faire un
choix de connaissances c'est une
surprise tout même cette annonce de
départ vous ne l'aviez pas annoncé au
moment de la campagne non encore il ya
tout juste un an vous n'en parlez pas
non du tout c'est que celle que j'avais
vous en doutez on se présente pas par
hasard donc j'avais énormément pesé
déjà en 2008 ce choix et puis ça a
maturé tout doucement dans les derniers
mois
ce choix à la fois deux soirs mener une
liste et de me représenter et repartir
pour au moins 4 5 années dans l'autre
mandat pour refaire le
la même anticipation au passé dès
maintenant si ça s'étend de plus je
crois qu'il faut être raisonnable j'ai
l'impression que je ne souhaiterais pas
du moins avoir la fatigue de rendre
service à mes habitants ça c'est pour la
raison que vous nous expliquer il ya
aussi des rumeurs forcément dans la
ville suisse circulent on parle de votre
état de santé notamment aurait coûté le
poste de maire pour cette raison non du
tout du tout aucune autre rumeur n'a de
raison d'être
mais c'est la règle de la vie on aime
dire que l'on sait ou que l'on connaît
eh bien ma foi j'y suis malheureusement
comme l'ensemble de mes collègues
habitués et j'ai du vernis à ce niveau
là ça me pose aucun problème
vous n'avez pas le sentiment non plus
d'abandonner ceux qui ont voté pour vous
en 2008 pour ce deuxième mandat en cours
de route je crois pas parce que d'abord
le parcours
même s'il faut être très humble par le
plus tôt pour mon équipe
et puis j'avais je vous le disais aucune
difficulté de mener une liste de me
représenter
même si toute élection et doit être
gagnée il n'en reste pas moins que je
donne le maximum de mon coeur
et puis anticipé je pense que les gens
peuvent le comprendre je vous disais
tout à l'heure une ville c'est une
grosse responsabilité ça se prépare
vous allez rester au conseil municipal
ans et je vais rester au conseil
municipal pour les as pour les aider et
les accompagner tant que faire se peut
jusqu'en mars 2014 préparer avec eux la
campagne électorale je ne serai pas sur
la liste de mars 2014
vous êtes également le suppléant de
david douillet vous avait siégé aussi à
l'assemblée nationale lorsque david
douillet est entrée au gouvernement
si jamais il était nécessaire que vous
retournez à l'assemblée comme vous êtes
suppléant vous iriez oui vous vous
mettez entre parenthèses sept partis
politiques lors du tour j'irais bien sûr
je n'avais clé avec david douillet
justement cette démission par exemple de
la municipalité de plaisir à bien sûr je
l'évoqué à la fois avec
le député david douillet je les fais
également avec le président du conseil
général et monsieur le préfet michel jau
vous avez beaucoup discuté autour de ça
ou vous avez pris cette décision seul
comment vous avez réussi à aboutir à
cette conclusion qu'il fallait mieux
partir maintenant comme vous l'expliqué
écouter bien sûr familialement également
vous en doutez un évidemment la famille
il est très importante dans ses choix
parce que c'est pas une décision qu'on
prend à la légère
nantes mais je vous ai dit je les mature
et pendant plusieurs mois tranquillement
et depuis que je les ai prises je suis
de plus en plus certain que c'est la
bonne solution
le alors ma décision était prise je ne
suis pas un garçon qui revient
facilement sur sa décision mais j'ai su
convaincre et au moins au niveau de
l'ensemble de l'équipe municipale j'ai
pas eu à convaincre
ils ont compris et à la fois accompagné
ce que je les en remercie
on va rappeler tout de même votre
carrière politique des buts en 83 ou
étiez conseiller municipal d'opposition
sur la ville de plaisir
élu au conseil régional en 92 conseiller
général des yvelines dans le canton
plaisir en 98 2000 un élu maire de
plaisir pour l'ump réélu en 2008
également aidé le premier tour 2004 vous
avez perdu le canton plaisir vous avez
été aussi on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
elle députés quel a été le moment le
plus fort dans cette carrière politique
a sans aucun doute gagné la ville de
plaisirs sucrés tels dati n'est donc par
les socialistes au paraguay oui mais
c'est pas ça qui est le moment le plus
fort c'est pas d'avoir battu les
socialo-communistes pour moi le moment
plus fort ça a été que moi gosse de
plaisir est ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
un jour en culottes courtes que j'avais
un rendez vous avec ma ville jamais donc
ça a été quelque chose qui m'a
énormément ému et ça reste quelque chose
de très fort que qui vont m'accompagner
jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
vous êtes agriculteur de profession
comme votre fils d'ailleurs comment vous
avez décidé de vous engager en politique
à quelle occasion
ça a été un accident c'est plutôt la
politique est venu vers moi que moi qui
suis allé à la politique j'ai été assez
malheureux de de la politique était
menée sur la ville de plaisir et j'ai
souhaité nationalement également en 80
c'était l'élection de françois
mitterrand je partage respect mais je ne
partageais pas bien sûr ses volontés là
je me suis dit qu'est ce que je fais
pour mon pays qu'est ce que je fais pour
ma ville pour que les choses évoluent
dans l'esprit que j'ai et c'est comme
cela que les choses démarrent
tranquillement à la base
et puis après bien c'est la rencontre de
personnes qui vous feront aller dans des
responsabilités ou non quel bilan vous
faites forcément vous allez me dire vous
êtes satisfait du travail mené sur cette
commune mais il ya tout de même certains
dossiers où j'imagine vous êtes plus
satisfait que sur d'autres d'avoir pu
mener à leur terme mais évidemment c'est
un ces normes et mans 2-2 sentiments
contrasté vous voulez toujours donner
plus et plus vite et vous commencez déjà
à prendre qu'une administration c'est
lent c'est important ça travaille très
bien mais c'est lent quand vous venez du
domaine privé ça vous surprend
énormément
et puis en même temps j'ai découvert
énormément de choses les associations le
milieu scolaire l'enseignement j'avais
mes idées préconçues
peut-être comme chacun par rapport aux
professions des autres et on s'aperçoit
avec les choses sont pas blanches ou
noires c'est gris alors faut aussi que
ça soit le plus gris clair possible est
bon à prendre en marche en apprend à
connaître les gens se nourrit de toutes
ces personnes là et ça m'a construit
énormément pendant toutes ces années
nous sommes allés dans votre commune
aujourd'hui poser une simple question
que pensez vous de l'action de joël
regnault voici quelques réactions
quelques sentiments aujourd'hui dans
cette ville de plaisir en moi ne me
concerne pas c'est le seul nuage a
décidé de s'arrêter sa vie de mère
goethe ou quoi c'est un petit peu
dommage
à mon avis on voit ça a été un très bon
maire pendant deux cents
comme il est resté d'années il est resté
assez longtemps ou non non c'était
vraiment très très bon maire c'est un
bon maire après la ces raisons je pense
a donc personnellement je n'ai pas
vraiment d'avis là dessus je suis
absolument pas pourquoi il démissionne
donc je ne pourrais pas vous dire je
n'ai pas de réponse personnelle aussi
injuste je ne sais pas trop non moi ça
ça me ça me choque pas du tout moi parce
que je vous dis il ya peut-être des
petits problèmes aussi de de santé ou
c'est peut-être personnel on ya répondu
tout à l'heure à ces problématiques de
santé voilà c'était sur l'action sur le
fait de quitter cette municipalité
visiblement les plaisirs voire les peler
cervoise ne vont pas vous en tenir
rigueur non mais c'est gentil de leur
part depuis je trouve que c'est plutôt
drôlement sympathique des gens puissent
inquiéter même à un moment si un arrêt
peut avoir une raison différente
j'imaginais pas à ce point c'est
touchant
votre avis sur la commune également
aujourd'hui si on fait un petit bilan et
qu'on se base sur l'action politique
uniquement sur les choix que vous avez
pris quel regard vous avez sur cette
commune vous le disais tout à l'heure
vous êtes agriculteur aujourd'hui cette
commune est très marquée par la
circulation les très difficile de
circuler dans plaisir beaucoup de
centres commerciaux également c'est
l'image de la ville que vous vouliez
lorsque vous êtes arrivé
non c'est pas spécialement l'image de la
ville que je voulais c'est l'image de la
ville qu'elle avait nous étions déjà
dans un hypermarché régional
d'importance et puis malheureusement eh
bien c'était la déstructuration
automatique des commerces de proximité
on sait pertinemment que dans la société
d'aujourd'hui développer le commerce de
proximité ça n'existe pour ainsi dire
plus il ya plus de jeunes qui se lancent
qui s'endettent pour 20 ans avec les
difficultés qu'on peut connaître les uns
et les autres donc
l'hypermarché a son importance et puis
en même temps malheureusement je me suis
battu bien sûr pour la déviation des
usines d'incinération d'ordures qu'on a
gagné puisqu'il y avait plus de 800
camions poids lourds jour aller retour
qui traversait cette commune reste plus
l'aménagement du rd 30 c'est le
département conseiller général du canton
à l'heure actuelle j'espère continuer à
y travailler il ya beaucoup de retard de
prix je le regrette
ça devrait être fini pour fin 2013 on
pense que sa partie jusqu'en 2014 à 2016
nous serons encore patient mais il faut
y arriver c'est indispensable
on a quand même plus de 40 mille
véhicules jour qui polluent la ville et
ça augmente et avec les centres
commerciaux qui se sont étendus ou bien
du centre commercial qui était là
lorsque vous êtes arrivé en 2001 mais
depuis ça s'est étendue vers les
clayes-sous-bois notamment oui oui tout
à fait mais c'est pas normal non plus
que la ville des clayes-sous-bois ait
voulu développer à l'image de plaisir
son centre commercial maintenant c'est
tout un ensemble qui au delà nos cirques
ont fait d'un euro comme sur la propre
communauté c'est vraiment étendu sur les
souliers de ville dans dans les yeux de
l'ensemble des habitants tous assez
plaisir les clés tout ça on était c'est
un centre commercial
on va pas s'en plaindre il faut savoir
également que ça représente plus de la
moitié des impôts des habitants la ville
a quand même cette force
elle est très attractive ça nous aide
également vous avez vu dernièrement n'a
eu la chance pour la deuxième année
consécutive et là je le dis avec
beaucoup de réserve mais ô combien ravi
de voir le chômage baisser de 3 9% sur
la ville alors que partout ça éclate
nous sommes la seule ville la deuxième
année du département que son chômage
baisse ne cherchons pas pourquoi on a la
chance bien sûr de ne pas avoir de
société automobile mais en même temps on
a la première hyper marché intéressant
et d'être dans un triangle attractif on
sait de développer c'est tant mieux mais
je reviens tout de même sur cette image
de la ville qui s'urbanise par exemple
encore aujourd'hui il ya des
constructions des lotissements sur des
parties agricoles sur des champs qui
disparaissent c'est pas des champs
qu'ils ont cultivé
donc sachant de quoi on parle c'était
sur une zone industrielle qui avait la
société que j'ai fait faire la déviation
pour que les camions de cette société
puisse être sûr thiverval grignon donc
c'était des friches industrielles qu'il
faut dépolluer d'ailleurs donc déjà
première chose et puis vous rendez
compte que toutes les constructions qui
lie à actuelle malgré le pays lui qui a
été votée en 2007 nous permet simplement
de se maintenir au nombre d'habitants
c'est à dire on était trente deux mille
habitants
on finira
le mandat en dessous de 32 mille
habitants au bout de 12 ans pour toutes
les raisons qu'on connaît les uns et les
autres la déstructuration
malheureusement de la vie de famille ou
où les séparations il faut de logements
se situent en avec un enfant aussi un
qui n'écrivent s'installe bien sûr on
souhaite qualité plaisir et qu'on peut
pas leur offrir donc la ville est à 32
mille habitants on va dire à 500
habitants près ne bougera pas sur toutes
les années qui se présentent devant nous
je crois que l'équilibré est pas si mal
trouvé une petite parenthèse puisqu'on
parle de logement la question du
quartier du valigot si c'était un
dossier important à gérer il était
encore pour rénover tout ce quartier
d'habitation et c'est pas un moment
évident forcément lorsqu'on est mais non
suite c'est très compliqué parce que il
faut vous mettre à la place des
locataires
là aussi c'est perturbant pour eux fo
est également du côté de l'opic vois pas
ce que vous avez besoin et le bailleur
social sur ce quartier bien sûr et qu'il
en a la responsabilité complète il faut
être facilitateur avec les entreprises
qui viennent travailler là dessus c'est
des gros dossiers qu'on se passerait
complètement c'est clair mais qu'il faut
mener à terme parce qu'il ne mérite
d'abord il peut on peut pas abandonner
les quartiers qu'il soit nous allons
donner la parole à présent à votre
opposition au conseil municipal parce
que vous démissionner mais il ya aussi
une campagne qui va s'engager pour 2014
le modem tout d'abord bruno tabary c'est
le chef de file également de ce
mouvement dans le département la voici
sa réaction à votre départ pour lui ce
n'est pas une surprise
ça se pratique beaucoup en france et en
ile de france de mettre en avant la
personne qu'on vous souhaite voire à sa
succession
donc vous effacer les plaisirs en 2008
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas voté pour madame
cohen berger
au mans je pense que de toute façon il
sera dans la continuité de ce qu'a fait
le maire aujourd'hui c'est un signe
fort de lancement de campagne il le fait
maintenant à peu près deux ans parce que
j'ai cru comprendre que les élections
municipales serait certainement repoussé
après les élections sénatoriales de 2014
histoire que la gauche perde pas trop de
postes sénatoriales s'il y avait un
changement dans le comportement des
électeurs en france donc oui c'est un
signe en tout cas de lancement de
campagne dès maintenant et ça c'est
clair et on parle bien de mars 2014 pour
les élections les homards sauf nouveau
nouveau changer si les départementales
et régionales qui sont poussés en 2015
seulement pour vous la campagne est
lancée pour rebondir sur ce qu'il en est
non non vous rentrez comme la campagne
des municipales que vous allez regarder
d'un coin de l'oeil maintenant que vous
êtes vous aller siéger au en tant que
simple conseiller et non plus en tant
que maire pour vous là pour le groupe
ump la campagne n'est pas lancée à pour
le groupe ump du tout toute façon c'est
la décision de l'équipe de joël et de
demain de ma région colmate vergy qui
compte sur la ville de plaisir et c'est
ce qui fait l'intérêt d'élections
municipales et dépasse de loin les
paysages politiques et démarrera à
l'automne sans aucun doute 2013 ça sera
bien assez tôt
il ya encore des dossiers qu'il faut
accompagner dont je vais garder la
charge parce que c'est des dossiers qui
viennent de très loin plaisir sable en
l'église saint pierre
il sait des gros dossiers qui dépasse de
loin d'ailleurs le cadre départemental
donc c'est la mémoire que je vais
essayer d'accompagner dans ces dossiers
là on a du travail avant les élections
municipales c'est clair vous l'avez
mentionné le nom de votre adjointe qui
devrait vous succéder lors du conseil
municipal en tout cas celle que vous
allez présenter au conseil municipal il
y aura une élection interne le 15
novembre je le rappelle joséphine
coleman berger pourquoi pourquoi ce
choix parce que c'est une personne ce
n'est pas votre première adjointe non du
tout du tout c'est l'adjointe au
culturel et à la communication à la
prouver sa qualité culturelle de tout ce
qu'elle a mis en place sur la ville de
plaisir qui était un désert culturel et
aujourd'hui vous le savez avec le
théâtre coluche avec le château qui fait
une des plus grosses manifestations et
de loin dépassant les frontières du
département qui escale d'ailleurs qui
attire plus de 10000 spectateurs par an
sur une après midi et c'est une personne
qui m'accompagne depuis 92 auprès de moi
et principalement sur la ville de
plaisir depuis 2001 c'est une personne
qui connaît tous les dossiers qui les a
soutenues avec moi et donc qui est prêt
qui est construite pour justement
prendre ce témoin et le mener dans la
même perspective et apporter son regard
nouveau sans aucun doute pour vous
c'était une évidence de la choisir oui
il ya un moment d'hésitation ou des
nervis vous avez su que ce serait un
leurre du tout j'ai su très rapidement
que ce serait elle qui la convainc du
tout du tout à savait que s'il y avait
quelque chose qui me serait arrivé
je lui avais demandé de faire le
nécessaire et puis elle est très
appréciée par l'ensemble des élus et
s'imposer aucun problème
on va écouter à présent l'opposition
socialiste le parti socialiste bernard
ansart pour lui aussi la campagne est
lancée même si vous nous avez dit de
votre côté la campagne n'était pas
lancée en tout cas vos opposants se sont
déjà en course à la campagne et
commençait d'ailleurs monsieur regnault
dans ses déclarations à la presse dit
clairement je mets en place ma dauphine
entre disney 1 donc pour faire voir aux
plaisirs wac
c'est là c'est celle qui leur faut et
que c'est elle qui va continuer ce que
j'ai commencé et nous ce n'est pas ce
que l'on veut
si je me fie à la politique culturelle
qui est appliqué sur la ville dont la
grosse majorité du budget est concentré
sur l'espace coluche
j'ai quelques inquiétudes quand même
pour l'avenir notre ville ce que l'on
déplore en tant qu'opposition c'est que
de toute façon on est mis à l'écart de
des dossiers de la ville
il n'y a pas de concertation c'est une
ville où il n'y a pas de concertation et
donc de fait et bien on est devant le
fait accompli
voilà joël regnault je vous faire réagir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit déjà sur le
manque de concertation
bon moi je respecte vous le savez les
interventions des uns et des autres
c'est pas très sérieux de façon s'il y
avait un manque de concertation
je pense que ça se traduirait quand vous
fait des micro-trottoirs que ce soit au
moment de noël ou quand vous nous
invitez il ya longtemps que le sentiment
serait ressorti au niveau de la ville et
puis je pense pas que l'élection en 2008
aurait pris la qualité qui a l'a pris
c'est une des rares communes qui a été
élu au premier tour face à une volonté
très forte puisque c'était
malheureusement pas ce que tu dis
malheureusement pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui plus là le secrétaire
départemental et patrick malivet sur la
vie de les hanter face à vous en 2008 et
vous aviez rose pressent sur 85 104
hisse donc des grosses prétentions qui
n'ont pas eu lieu d'être
il fait son job bon c'est normal que lui
il estime que la campagne est lancée
moi j'ai pas de remarque là dessus bon
je pense que tout simplement le rendez
vous avec les plus boisés les rois sera
le seul qui comptera pour les petites
choses après c'est pas d'importance
lorsqu'on est que vous écoute votre
opposant socialiste il évoque aussi
l'inquiétude éventuelle du côté de l'ump
on va tout de même rappeler aussi que
les dernières élections elle n'était pas
forcément très bonne pour l'ump si on
mentionne les législatives parce que
vous parliez des municipales
si on mentionne ces élections
législatives à plaisir c'est le parti
socialiste qui est arrivé en tête 53 47
% des voix pour frédérik bernard qui est
aussi le maire de poissy de vendre david
douillet et vous également puisque vous
êtes le suppléant david douillet ça a dû
être difficile de voir ce score et ça
dure ont entraîné quelques inquiétudes
de votre part de vous dire en 2014 ça
risque d'être plus compliqué la gauche
est arrivée en tête aux législatives
écoutez et assez nettement si j'avais pu
être majoritaire j'aurais été d'autant
plus content parce qu ils pas vous dire
le contraire on pas faire la langue de
bois ici il n'en reste pas moins que
chaque élection à son rôle est l'erreur
c'est de vouloir les mélanger vous avez
rappelé dresse terminal tout de même
écoutez vous est évidemment faux est
attentiste mais signale il a été
nationale et si ça n'avait pas été le
cas à plaisir ou de bien d'autres
communes et bien la majorité
affligeant que l'on a aujourd'hui au
gouvernement on n'en serait pas ainsi
donc le vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
à juste titre que j'avais perdu mon
mandat en 2004 de conseiller général et
ça m'a pas empêché grâce à l'ensemble de
l'équipe qui m'entoure de gagner et du
premier tour en 2008
donc vous voyez que j'attire l'attention
bien sûr des analystes mais de
l'ensemble des politiques est toujours
très prudent sur ses ventes et d'art
s'il n'y avait que les packs que la
valeur du vote des partis politiques je
crois qu'il y aurait plus de communistes
en france ayant encore des maires
communistes
qu'est ce qui est important pour les
habitants c'est pas qu'ils soient de
gauche ou droite c'est qu'ils rendent
service et qu'il soit présent et que la
ville évolue dans le bon sens je crois
que c'est ça qui est important et tant
mieux pour les élections de 2014 ces
municipales vous allez accompagner la
liste qui se présentera qui sera menée
par joséphine coleman s'immerger
normalement je l'accompagnerai seraient
présents sur cette liste aussi ah non ce
que je vous ai dit d'ailleurs je ne
serai pas sur la liste mais je
l'accompagnerai dans la campagne
électorale bien sûr et quels conseils
vous pourriez donner quelques conseils
vous allez donner à celle qui 2 c'était
frappe de riise g20 la prétention de
donner quelques conseils mais si je
devais en retenir qu'un seul c'est
d'être à l'écouté des habitants c'est de
garder son coeur le plus longtemps
possible et pas prendre trop de vernis
quand on y est lui resté sensible je
crois que c'est vraiment très important
joséphine coleman ce berger qui devrait
vous succéder ce sera le 15 novembre
lors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire sur la ville de plaisir
que pensez vous de cette élection
probable là aussi nous donnons la parole
aux plaisirs war et au plaisir oise si
elle peut faire comment comme le maire
oui pourquoi pas nous tout ce qu'on veut
c'est ça c'est que ça se passe bien
donc si c'est son adjoint qui voit
poindre la place ba on va voir ce que ça
va donner
chez que la connais pas du tout j'en ai
jamais entendu parler et je trouve que
c'est très très bien c'est une personne
qui est très très compétente et en plus
je vais vous dire une chose si d'autres
patronne pascal et c'est elle qui est
adjoint au maire de du culturel et nous
la paix tant plaisir détente évasion
nous sommes de la vie culturelle
donc pour nous c'est une fierté que soit
qu'elles viennent maire de plaisir je ne
sais pas je la connais pas vraiment
apparemment elle a travaillé avec
le maire à la suivit le truc est donc je
pense que c'est une bonne chose si c'est
dans la continuité du mode de ce que
faisait le maire six personnes à concots
n'est pas trop je trouvais on aurait pu
être prévenue avant quand même parce que
je trouve que c'est avec les concitoyens
je trouve que c'est pire une lettre un
petit peu avant pour nous la présenter
et verrait une réunion afin qu'on la
connaisse un petit peu plus sont qu'au
début c'est le premier adjoint qu elle
donc ce duel de premier adjoint à sa
place sur cette dernière intervention
montplaisir oise voilà qui nous dit que
l aurais aimé peut-être la connaître un
petit peu mieux la voir un petit peu
plus sur certains rendez vous la
rencontre et l'échangé avec oui sans
aucun doute c'est une réaction tout à
fait normal dans l'ordre des choses vous
douté quand vous prenez votre décision
vous commencez par vote exécutif
vous faites après l'ensemble de vos élus
votre directeur général des services
directeurs des cabinets votre
secrétariat et puis après vous allez
devant l'ensemble du personnel ce que
j'ai fait que j'ai réunis à l'espace
coluche et le courrier vient finaliser
dans toutes les boîtes aux lettres
ma volonté en essayant d'expliquer le
moins long possible parce que pour pas
embêtés des gens après vous savez quand
on fait des réunions on fait des
réunions de quartier et j'en fais tous
les ans tous les quartiers de la ville
en dehors des élections de façon à venir
au contact des gens si les gens auraient
voulu rencontrer mes adjoints ils sont
présents ça posait aucune difficulté
ils vont apprendre à la connaître dans
l'essentiel de décembre savez de son
édito il y aura bien sûr l'essentiel
c'est que j'ai mal dès les premiers mois
et bien sûr interview sur le maire et
interviews sur le nouveau maire donc les
gens vont s'habituer à elle et j'invite
toutes les personnes
quand il ya des événements des
manifestations à venir bien sûr la
rencontrer mais vous avez vu que
l'ensemble des personnes quand ils sont
interrogés sont quand même pas tellement
gentil à la fois sur mon départ et la
fois l'arrivée de madame coleman super g
c'est rassurant
vous allez allez à la rencontre vous
l'avez dire un peu plus des gens ça veut
dire que la campagne est lancée mais je
les fait j'ai fait tous les ans à leur
teneur particulière au printemps cette
année c'est d'ailleurs peut-être un peu
de campagnes de up vous mêmes vous
n'avez tout à l'heure pas de langue de
bois
non non non mais attendez est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on peut aller devant les
plaisirs oise et des plaisirs oies au
printemps à toutes les réunions de
quartier et que on va pas parler de
l'élection de mars 2014
évidemment donc la campagne était un peu
lent c'est étonnant allons-y c'est la
meilleure équipe est la meilleure pour
2014 selon vous pour ces élections
oui j'ai la meilleure candidate possible
pour votre groupe puisqu'on parle des
élections une toute dernière question
joël regnault françois fillon jean
françois copé pour l'ump y aura
l'élection ce week end le 18 novembre
françois fillon
votre et françois fillon oui comme david
douillet d'ailleurs oui ton quoi
pourquoi ce choix
parce que d'abord c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai participé et partager les deux
candidats dans le dans la période où
j'ai été élu député et
j'ai vraiment énormément apprécié la
façon dont monsieur fillon intervenait
et présenter ses dossiers
c'est un homme d'état c'est une évidence
merci joël regnault maire de plaisir
jusqu'au 15 novembre en tout cas ensuite
je vous serai au conseil municipal
après onze ans en tant que maire vous
allez passer la main vous êtes arrivé au
conseil municipal dans l'opposition
c'était en 1983 merci d'être venus
sursis un plateau le 11 novembre jour de
commémoration de l'armistice de la
guerre 14 18 un moment toujours célébrée
dans les différentes communes comme à
magny les hameaux et les enfants y ont
été associés le mémorial est le
réceptacle l'air qui accueille et qui
recueille qui préfet de la trace et
qu'il attend 11 novembre 1918
l'armistice marquer la fin des combats
de la première guerre mondiale c'est la
victoire des alliés et la défaite de
l'allemagne
chaque année des cérémonies sont
organisées dans les communes de france
ici à magny les hameaux depuis neuf ans
les enfants sont associés aux anciens
combattants pour faire un travail de
mémoire
le principe de ce lieu et de ne pas être
juste une pierre ou un lieu devant
lequel ont passé et qu'on pourrait
oublier au fur et à mesure des années il
est accompagné d'un livre qui est chaque
année refait avec une classe où
plusieurs accompagnés par les anciens
combattants qui travaillons sur toute
l'année pour se rappeler les
les personnes mortes pour la france
c'est vraiment le principe de faire
vivre cette mémoire et en la faisant
passer d'une génération à l'autre au fur
et à mesure ils ont tous un arrière un
grand père ou un arrière-grand-père soi
qui est décédé ou café maintenant
puisque gêne ou l'âge est la dernière
génération du feu quel est le shérif en
62 45 y en a plus beaucoup non plus donc
on est un peu le porteur de messages de
paix et tout pour les nouvelles
générations à venir
en espérant qu'on soit les derniers
anciens combattants de nombreux magny
cours assister à la cérémonie présidée
par le nouveau maire de la commune
visiblement ému c'est une très profonde
émotion particulièrement cette journée
du 11 novembre et comme je le disais
tout à l'heure
j'ai eu le privilège de connaître mon
grand-oncle puisqu'il est mort au delà
des 90 ans
et quand j'étais
petit à l'âge des enfants qui étaient là
mon grand oncle me racontez nous
raconter à ma famille l'épreuve de de
verdun dont il a été un des rares
survivants
outre la sensibilisation auprès des
jeunes générations la fnaca se bat
depuis 50 ans pour que l'état
reconnaisse la guerre d'algérie c'est
chose faite depuis peu le 19 mars est
désormais la date officielle de la fin
de la guerre jour de commémoration